the the saddest
type of infidelity in my opinion is the
mistake
which is someone just makes a mistake
they they just people do dumb when
it comes to sex like people just
in a moment
you know they sub they follow temptation
their impulse control is poor you know
and they they do something that they
that doesn't reflect their morality or
doesn't reflect the depth of their
feelings like if you spend enough time
in a room with people who've cheated
in a relationship and are speaking
candidly to you about it because you're
their lawyer
they'll say to you very openly like no I
really love my wife I really love my
wife like I just I don't know I was just
an idiot like I just you know I saw this
bright shiny object and I went for it I
really wanted to sleep with that woman
like I I wanted to I wanted to her
I love my wife I make love to my wife I
love my wife but I just want to sleep
with this one you know and we created a
culture where
one of those eradicates the other
I I don't that's a whole nother
discussion is you know or is there
ethical non-monogamy like should we is
marriage
about who I have sex with
or is marriage a different kind of a
partnership is it of is it a pair bond
that's about building a life together
you know and where does monogamy fit
into that and people like Esther perel
and they're they're those are people who
are making very intelligent
discussions about that
you know yeah that's a complicated one
just to actually just Linger on that a
view how often have people with
open marriages have been in your office
well let's see and this is one of those
like
from a research perspective this would
be flawed because I see the they're in
my office because their marriage is
falling apart so there may be lots of
people
having open relationships that don't end
up in a divorce lawyer's office so I'd
never meet them but I meet a lot of
people that that was the Hail Mary pass
sure like I meet a lot of people that
they tried that but it in retrospect it
was a Hail Mary pass it was like uh look
we've just figured let's try this you
know like maybe it's maybe this will
this will keep the glue together on this
thing you know and and
um and I've also seen open open
relationships go wrong
you know where we agree we're just going
to have sexual connections with other
people or we're going to bring other
people into the bedroom
um but together like we're going to be
together with other people or with
another person and then that that
connection of those two people
like do you think it's a soul mate all
of a sudden now and it goes in this
other because and again is that novelty
is that like it's the reason why I don't
understand why people have threesomes
it's kind of like
you know when someone sings to you I
don't know where to look
like I don't know where to look like if
someone's singing to me I don't know
where to look like it feels weird right
like this is a conundrum no this
I'll say this too this will never but I
it's the reason I can't go to strip
clubs yeah I don't know where to look
like if I go to strip club you know like
you go to strip club and and there's you
know the part where they the woman's on
the stage and she walks past each person
who does a little thing and then next
person and the next little thing
so when she's right in front of you
I like a woman's face and I like a
woman's body I like both of them so I'm
looking at the woman's face which is
very beautiful but she's naked and I
think oh she's naked I should be looking
at her naked body because obviously
that's like it's almost rude not to
because she's naked in front of me of
course since then I'm looking at her
naked body which is lovely to look at
but then I find myself going oh my God
you're just still like you should look
at her face for God's sakes yeah and
then I look at your face and find myself
having this whole thing in my head where
I'm going like oh my God where am I
supposed to look so I think a threesome
with
two women you don't hardly know or
you're not that's different
but a threesome with a long-term partner
who you're in a relationship with and a
new person
seems to me a very dangerous ground
because you're going to want to enjoy
the novelty of this new person but
you're gonna have to spend time with
this person after
so how much attention do you spend to
the new novel exciting thing without
creating the impression that you don't
you're not interested in this because
you want you're my favorite person but
this is fun so I want to just try this
for a few but then also I don't want to
forget about that like it it just seems
tricky that analogy by the way is
brilliant and also I guess it's tricky
because the consequences of mistakes are
quite High because you're gonna have to
talk about it wait and there's there's
an easy way to misinterpret the data
right like so if I'm
if I really like sleeping with my
partner but I get one chance to sleep
with this other person like well of
course I should indulge in that because
I can do this anytime like what it you
know but but this person my partner
might interpret that as oh so you're
more interested in her than me because
that voice in in my partner that would
be you know insecure might hear that you
know so I I just why would you even why
would you open yourself up to that level
of chaos you seem to love chess in the
courtrooms it's the kind of uh intimate
human chess of sorts yeah no that's
that's too high risk how do we get on
threesomes oh open open marriages well
we got how do we get on threesomes I
don't know I always wondering how people
get into threesomes
um I figure they like if one is fun two
must be better if two is better three
must be better
um yeah I I think we we the way that
that this becomes an issue is
why would you have a non-monogamous
relationship
what is it about your sex life with this
person that's not satisfying and I think
that that is the question that's harder
to ask yourself and to try to answer
with your partner